now it's going to be a big week in
scotland which could determine the fate
of the first minister nicholas sturgeon
there are not one but
two reports due into the way in which
the scottish government
mishandled complaints of sexual
misconduct against alex salmond
and whether nicola sturgeon personally
break the ministerial code by misleading
the scottish parliament
about what she knew and when
we're joined now by the scottish health
secretary gene freeman
if nicolas sturgeon is found to have
broken the ministerial code
should she resign well we don't have
either of those two confirmed reports
yet so
we're getting a bit of ahead of
ourselves the most important one
is actually the independent inquiry into
whether the first minister
reached the ministerial code that she
referred herself to
in january 2019. we expect that report
this week and that is the one where uh
james hamilton the qc is has looked at
all of these matters and he
will produce his conclusions that's
that's the one that is genuinely
independent
and objective and we will see what that
report says
and then the first minister will take
the necessary decisions after that
a poll for sky news found that 51 of
people thought that nicola sturgeon
should resign
if she broke the ministerial code just
35 said she should stay in her job
and she of course has spoken about the
importance of it too it you know when
she launched the minister of code in
2018 she said i'll lead by example
in following the letter and spirit of
the code surely
if she is found to have broken the code
she needs to go doesn't she
well the first minister has led by
example
throughout and i think the public
particularly the public in scotland have
seen
how open and frank her leadership is
uh particularly over the last year when
we've been dealing with the pandemic
the the committee report is not yet
concluded what we have
is unattributable briefings and leaks
from that committee which is actually
as it happens against the msp code of
conduct so
the the situation here is important it's
serious what's most serious
actually is that the scottish government
made serious mistakes
in handling and implementing the policy
on harassment and the people who have
suffered most
in that are the women who brought those
complaints that's what the committee
was supposed to be looking at but even
before
the first minister appeared in front of
that committee and for eight hours
answered their questions
even before that the scottish
conservatives were calling for her
resignation
so i think we can dismiss some of that
at least as a bit of parties and
politics
40 odd days out from a scottish election
and focus our attention
on what the genuine the independent
report
from mr hamilton qc says when we receive
that i hope this week
not uh long to wait for that i'm keen to
talk to you about covid as well because
of course
we've had these issues of vaccine
supplies a delayed shipment from india
nicola sturgeon saying this week
scotland is going to have half a million
fewer doses over the next month than
anticipated what does that mean for the
vaccine rollout in scotland
well what it means is that there is a
lot
of we we model every single day the
anticipated supply against the scheduled
appointments
we think having remodeled on the basis
that
those 500 doses will not come when we
expected them to come
we do expect them to come later but they
won't come when we thought
we still believe that we are able to
meet our commitment which was
that we will offer a vaccination
appointment to everyone
in those jcbi priority groups one to
nine so that's everyone
over 50 and those people with underlying
health conditions are clinically
extremely vulnerable
and unpaid carers and we believe we're
still on track to do that
and to have vaccinated all adults over
18 in scotland by the end of july and
we're
over 2 million vaccinated now
so we keep looking at it every day what
we have to be sure to do though
is make sure that not only can we
deliver first roses
but that we are delivering the second
dose which is very important
within the 12-week window so that's the
work that's underway and
as of today we still are confident that
we can make that
mid-april commitment and we'll keep on
looking at it every day i look at it
every day and my officials work on it
constantly
um of course primary schools in scotland
have been reopened for some time now the
youngest pupils going back on the 22nd
of february
you must have some data coming in by now
and what does it
show when it comes to rising cases so
there's been
a small uptick in cases but it is
it is small uh and we keep an eye on
that all the time the
case positivity number which is also one
of as you know one of the
important uh bits of information that
you look at all the time
it remains relatively low but
we just monitor this all the time uh and
we
said and all the steps that we set out
the first minutes to set out on tuesday
just gone
about how we intend to ease restrictions
second of april fifth of april end of
april
uh all of that of course is dependent on
continuing to keep
virus numbers low and bring it down case
numbers down even from where it is just
now
on the one hand and be able to deliver
the vaccination
program on the other so we remain
cautiously optimistic that we are still
on track
but i think everybody knows all your
viewers will know and certainly those in
scotland know
that this is a constant exercise and
what we are
desperately trying to avoid so the
approach is cautious
is that we turn to a third locked up
nobody nobody wants that
individually for people's mental health
and well-being seeing family and friends
but also in economic terms and
absolutely in terms of people's health
just finally um on a quite different
subject
if i may and a rangers football player
this week glenn camara said he was being
racially abused by a slavia plague
player
now i'm not going to repeat the words
because frankly they are far too
offensive
um but for months footballers have been
taking the
knee for black lives matter if no action
is taken
in the face of racist abuse is football
just plain lip service
well of course it's up to it is up to
the football authorities the club and
the football authorities
both in scotland and as i think
internationally
uh but i would hope it's not enough to
be
uh against racism you've got to actively
be anti-racist
uh in the same way as you have to be
actively anti-misogynist you know
it's not enough to say i'm not racist
you need to call it out
and deal with it so i would hope that
the proper investigation is done there
and the proper action is taken
because really in this century we should
be well
uh insulting and dismissing and down
diminishing fellow human beings on the
base of
of their race their color their sex any
disability these things are just
ridiculous in this day and age and we
need to do something about it
okay gene freeman thank you very much
for being on the program thank you